imagina uma mulher de 30 anos no exato
momento que ela percebe que está dentro
de um labirinto podem imaginado que é o
tempo o pessoal tá precisando para
voltar aqui mas não tem problema não
não consigo imaginar bem ok então
eu vou continuar ok então imagina
imagina foco
imagine essa mulher de 30 anos no exato
momento em que ela se dá conta que está
no labirinto e percebe que está
completamente perdida e não tem a menor
noção de onde fica a saída aos 20 e
poucos anos eu larguei tudo e comecei
muitos movimentos na minha vida do zero
eu morava aqui em joão pessoa fui morar
na alemanha era formado em química
industrial resolver cursar arquitetura
nova faculdade novos amigos nova casa
nova cultura
e aí
aos 30 anos duas faculdades no bolso
dominando três idiomas e aí você está
pensando que estava me sentindo a rainha
da cocada preta não foi nessa fase que
eu achei que tinha tudo que eu percebi
que não tinha nada e aí eu me sinto
realmente totalmente perdida mas claro
que estou aqui hoje também para explicar
que explicar para vocês como eu fiz pra
sair desse labirinto
nós enxergamos o mundo através de
filtros e é por isso que existem os
diversos pontos de vista
para entender melhor como é que a gente
filtra nós podemos usar a programação
neurolinguística a pnl nlp foi estudada
nos anos 70 por americanos
eles estudaram o nosso comportamento foi
rija bela eo john grinder sustentar
melhor a minha fala hoje eu também vou
querer explicar para vocês
um conceito da neuro sistêmica tá
sei que você está olhando pra mim com
carabineiros sistêmica revelou o que eu
vou explicar tá esse conceito de janeiro
o sistema é um pouco mais atual
ele começou com milton erickson lá pra
1911 existem outras pessoas que
continuam estudando como por exemplo do
togo transmite então alemão que teve
inclusive a chance de conhecer os dois
meses a neuro sistêmica explica o poder
do nosso cérebro sob as nossas reações
voluntárias e involuntárias e o temo que
eles utilizaram anômina lizar o foco da
nossa atenção é o prime e aí os meninos
já fizeram algumas dinâmicas com vocês
eu vou querer explicar para vocês é como
foi que eu fiz esse experimento na minha
casa do meu pai me eu escolhi meu quarto
escolher uma cor que foi a cor verde e
resolvi cronometrar o tempo dois minutos
contar todos os tons de venda no meu
quarto é inicial tempo dois minutos com
tal estão de tons de verde e fiz isso em
três etapas a primeira etapa dois
minutos
contei 40 tons de verde no meu quarto
segunda rodada dois minutos
contei 59 tons de verde no meu quarto
terceira rodada dois minutos
contei 82 tons de verde no meu quarto
sim era o meu quarto tá não mudei foi
para a sala no jardim realmente era o
quarto também não alterei o tempo o que
realmente mudou gente foi a minha
percepção que eu conseguir visualizar
mais possibilidades através do prime ou
seja nós podemos escolher onde é que a
gente vai focar nossa atenção para
ampliar as nossas possibilidades
tá e aí na minha história eu resolvi me
conectar com aquilo que eu não conhecia
durante muito tempo eu acreditei que
conhecer novos países e novas culturas
ea refinaria
olhar e foi por isso que eu escolhi não
focar naquilo que eu conhecia e sim
focar no novo
foi assim que eu fiz as minhas escolhas
na vida
e aí eu quero aproveitar também para
interagir um pouquinho com vocês e fazer
algumas provocações
neste momento do meu toque pode ser que
algumas pessoas estejam 100% focados
aqui em mim na minha fala mas pode ser
que outros de vocês estejam focados no
lindo cenário que foi preparado aqui ou
inclusive no próprio colega que está ao
lado
e será que tem alguém aqui que está
pensando naquilo que não conseguiu fazer
ainda hoje ainda vai ter que dar conta
até o final do dia ou apesar dos meninos
terem pedido será que tem alguém aqui
focado no visor no celular
imagina que você está e sempre sempre
focada em mim
agora tenho um celular vibra se recebe
uma mensagem e quando você olha conteúdo
é algo que vai te deixar nervosa por
algum motivo milésimos de segundo
você altera a sua fisiologia você nem
percebe mas o foco da atenção
mudou a sua fisiologia ea notícia boa
para vocês e pra mim também a respeito
do prime é que nós conseguimos decidir
onde é que vamos focar nossa atenção eu
posso focar no novo ou no desconhecido
no problema ou na solução possa focar na
cor verde do meu quarto ou no vermelho
posso focar aqui no meu toque ou no
visor do meu celular
essa escolha minha essa escolha é sua
e aí eu gostaria de ter aqui um
pouquinho mais com vocês
eu queria saber vou fazer umas perguntas
e vou querer que vocês apenas levanta a
mão quem de vocês aqui essa platéia
maravilhosa
nesse momento também focada em processos
internos de autoconhecimento levanta a
mão pra mim por favor
ok quem de vocês aqui nessa platéia
maravilhosa está focado em novo
desbravar um novo saber o que está
acontecendo no mundo levanta pra mim por
favor
ótimo e quem de vocês aqui faz tudo
junto e misturado está fazendo tudo ao
mesmo tempo olhando pra dentro e olhando
pra fora
já tem a ver com vocês aqui em então é
isso é o agente decide onde é que a
gente vai levar a nossa atenção o nosso
prime está obrigado por participar
comigo e aí eu gostaria de trazer para
vocês agora mais uma ferramenta da
programação neurolinguística que são os
níveis neurológicos que foram
desenvolvidos por um americano chamado
robert dilts em 1975 e ele é explica as
nossas vivências através de níveis
eu tive a chance de encontrar com deus
agora em fevereiro em congresso e
mostrei pra ele a interpretação que eu
fiz dos níveis neurológicos que eu vou
propor para vocês aqui embarcar comigo
numa viagem quando eu senti que eu
estava totalmente perdida
eu resolvi fazer um mergulho interno
olhar pra dentro
eu utilizei essa ferramenta foi como se
eu tivesse aberto sete gatinhos do meu
cérebro para reorganizar e reconecta
algumas coisas que precisavam ter um
pequeno ajuste
aí eu chamo vocês vem comigo no caminho
eu explico para fazer essa viagem comigo
qual é o propósito maior é que faz você
levantar todos os dias com aquela
sensação de ser a pessoa certa no lugar
certo
o teu sistema pensa um pouco nas pessoas
que fazem parte do teu sistema nos seus
amigos na tua família na tua profissão
você você está ocupando seu lugar no
sistema
e aí eu queria que vocês parassem para
pensar sobre a questão da identidade
qual é o dna está estampado no meu peito
quais as frases que me representam os
livros que eu tenho da minha estante os
artistas que eu curto
a imagem que as pessoas têm de mim me
representa 100% quais as crenças que
apóiam nas todas as sessões e quais as
crenças que delimitam além disso quais
são os seus valores e você tá congruente
com isso com os seus valores ea sua
profissão
será que você precisa fazer algum ajuste
de percurso
depois de embarcar tanto será que tem
algo que você precisa modificar
reorganizar
já parou pra pensar sobre os seus
hábitos que aptos você precisa reiniciar
o começar do zero e comportamentos não
estão ajudando atingir seus objetivos e
por fim é importante pensar no atual
contexto pessoal e profissional no
ambiente nessa gavetinha será que
precisa também fazer algum ajuste
o meu mergulho foi muito profundo
eu posso falar pra vocês que eu mudei
muitas coisas na minha vida depois de
passar por esse processo
começando pelo meu país depois de dez
anos na alemanha
eu resolvi que era hora de voltar e há
cinco anos eu voltei para a minha casa
na cidade onde eu nasci
e aí eu revi muitos hábitos
comportamentos mas tem um hábito meu
novo eu queria compartilhar com vocês
comecei a caminhar na praia eu conhecia
o mar nós não via e hoje eu tenho uma
relação maravilhosa com o mar
também tem outra coisa para compartilhar
com vocês aqui hoje eu não trabalho mais
com química
eu não trabalho com arquitetura queria
dizer a minha mãe meu pai que pode ficar
tranqüilo e não vou mudar de profissão
de novo
hoje eu trabalho com desenvolvimento de
pessoas imagina que eu tenho que começar
eu quis começar uma nova profissão do
zero
me formei me capacitei ainda continuo me
capacitando pra isso é um prazer eu amo
a minha profissão
a diferença mãe é que eu quero fazer
isso todos os dias da minha vida eu amo
meu trabalho
antes eu acreditava sorte no amor
azar na profissão hoje eu acredito que é
possível sim ter sucesso na vida pessoal
e profissional
e tem outra crença que eu queria
compartilhar com vocês
é possível sim se encontrar
se você quiser além disso que é um valor
meu que estava muito adormecido quando
eu fiz o meu mergulho e eu heat ver ele
na minha vida que é o valor da liberdade
a liberdade de ser
e aí eu quero compartilhar uma
historinha pra falar um pouquinho da
minha identidade pessoas que me conhecem
muitas pessoas aqui que me conhecem sem
saber se não soubessem que essa história
é minha
com certeza pensar em mim há 15 anos
antes de voltar eu fui para dublin com a
amiga foi para a casa dela era no meio
do meu aniversário ea gente foi no
parque
nós fomos no parque e eu me descobri
também poeta isa gosta de escrever
poesia eu estava usando uma rosa
vermelha no cabelo um óculos vermelho
charlie também era vermelho como no park
em dublin num dia de sol abrimos uma
taça de vinho e eu escrever uma poesia
com ela e o nome da minha poesia é a
liberdade a vermelha
isso diz muito sobre a minha identidade
e aí eu chego no meu sistema que é algo
maior
vou falar uma coisa pra vocês eu fiquei
tanto tempo morando fora tanto tempo
longe das minhas origens e quando
resolvi voltar pra cá eu precisei me
reposicionar precisei me posicionar na
minha família eu precisei me
reposicionar na minha profissão eu
precisei me posicionar com os meus
amigos e eu preciso agregar à parte do
meu sistema que estava totalmente quando
desconectadas e isso fez toda a
diferença
e aí eu conto toda essa história pra
vocês vão falar de algo que é
maravilhoso que é você ter um propósito
maior na sua vida e eu não quero pregar
aqui que eu acordei um dia com flores e
um cartãozinho que dizia eu sou o seu
propósito não foi assim
tá foi um caminho muito longo e eu
sofria a síntese tive momentos acendê de
muita dúvida porque não têm um manual
pra te ajudar a encontrar o seu
propósito maior
o que eu posso dizer para vocês aqui foi
um processo
as coisas foram clareando eu estou aqui
com vocês agora
como se pra mim foi muito claro qual é o
meu propósito maior
o meu propósito maior hoje é conectar
idéias e pessoas
talvez por ter ficado tanto tempo longe
da minha terra natal e tanto tempo sem
querer olhar para ela hoje eu tenho um
quarentão especial por joão pessoa
comecei fazendo alguns convites de
trabalho para pessoas até de outros
países e hoje a situação é assim
tá todo mundo querendo vim pra cá porque
essa cidade é linda e eu tenho o maior
prazer de fazer parte disso
e aí chegou a hora de eu pedir a vocês
não sei se vocês receberam um todo mundo
recebeu mostra pra mim show me isso é
depois que eu passei por todo esse
processo eu tomei algumas decisões
hoje eu trabalho com o pensamento
sistêmico e no sistema
a gente não joga nada fora a gente
agrega todas as partes só que é o meu
caminho é o meu sistema como vocês viram
aqui e resolvi fazer o meu caminho
inverso
resolvi voltar e nessa volta eu me
reintegrei com as minhas partes
eu me despedir de algumas histórias e
honrei algumas situações que me fizeram
evoluir e hoje eu estou aqui tá esse
novelo que vocês estão segurando eu dou
de presente pra vocês é o sistema de
vocês e esse labirinto aí tem várias
opções de saída
cada um aqui vai descobrir em algum
momento ou já descobriu qual é a sua
muito obrigada